figaro là et veut bienvenue bonjour à
tous il est un petit peu plus de 15
heures 30 il est 15h30 de exactement et
nous sommes en direct sur lefigaro.fr et
sur la page youtube du figaro la page
figaro live pour suivre en direct et
commenté la troisième sortie dans
l'espace de la sorte de l'astronaute
français thomas pesquet bonjour à tous
dans le chat je vais vous lire et je
suis d'ailleurs votre voix n'hésitez pas
à poser toutes vos questions à donner
des commentaires je les lirai en direct
je suis en plateau en studio avec cyril
van der berg vanlerberghe part dit
bonjour cyril bonjour brume bienvenue
alors cyril vous êtes rédacteur en chef
du service sciences et médecine du
figaro et spécialiste des questions de
l'espace cyril va répondre à toutes vos
questions
alors n'hésitez pas à poser les dans le
chatt jeu le jeu les relierait en direct
alors on va démarrer tout de suite avec
les images en direct de la nasa
ryad derrière moi à la régie palais
voulait mettre donc apparemment thomas
pesquet et en est déjà dans l'espace
depuis une heure et quart cervin 1h20 et
nous sommes dans un moment de nuit nous
allons voir dans quelques instants les
images qui nous parviennent en direct
depuis les ss et on va les commenter
tout de suite alors là c'est pas très
spectaculaire mais on voit quand même un
des astronautes qui se déplace à bas à
droite de l'image et il ya un moyen très
simple de repérer si c'est thomas
pesquet ou l'américain son coéquipier
chenkin bros c'est qu'il ya des bandes
rouges sur le scaf ans et je vois les
bandes rouges c'est thomas pesquet droit
de l'image qui est en train de se
déplacer et qui va en fait installer des
panneaux solaires c'est le but de la
sortie
c'est le but de sa de sa mission en fait
c'est quelque part c'est le moment le
plus important de sa liaison dans
l'espace sur la trèche votation
[Musique]
alors là on voit ses gants j'imagine
c'est la caméra du test jeu thomas
gasquet on voit là la f10 aux photos que
j ce qui donnera main gauche et
c'est une vraie action de mécano qui va
faire il faut qui dévisse davis de
maintien et accroche les nouveaux
panneaux solaires un support métallique
convoi au premier plan c'est le support
métallique
ces panneaux solaires ils ont ils ont
été montés sur la station par un cargo
dragon ii lancé par une fusée de space x
il ya quelques semaines ils ont été
installées à l'extérieur de la station
sur une base mobile bien petit comme un
petit train qui se balade le long de
l'axé central de la station et qui a
amené ces panneaux les plus proches
possibles de l'endroit ils vont être
installés et qui est maintenant il faut
les biens il faut les dévissé pour
qu'ils puissent être être démontés et
installer leur place finale alors
bâtisse neveu dans le chat de la page
youtube du figaro nous pose déjà une
toute première question merci à vous de
nous suivre
ils nous demandent si c'est la toute
première sortie de thomas dans l'espace
ou pas alors thomas parce qu'ils avaient
déjà fait deux sorties en 2017
dans sa première mission dans la station
spatiale internationale et s'il en fait
une troisième aujourd'hui c'est parce
que ça c'était super bien passé la
première fois il avait on peut le dire
vraiment à pressurer les experts
américains
il avait absolument réussi tous les
objectifs que deux sorties dans l'espace
avec à chaque fois un peu de temps un
peu de temps d'avancé à dire qu'ils
avaient réussi les opérations demandées
et voilà assez facilement et son
coéquipier de l'époque c'était sean
quinn bros celui qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui à ses côtés donc c'est un
duo de scaphandrier dans l'espace qui
est déjà expérimenté ils ont déjà
travaillé ensemble ils se connaissent
parfaitement et est pour le moment la
somme au bout d'une heure et une heure
vingt de la sortie à l'air se dérouler
exactement comme prévu
les images sont pas très spectaculaires
on voit toujours la caméra de casques
dos thomas pesquet je crois parce qu'on
est du côté nuit ont fait le tour de la
terre en une heure et demie à bord de la
station spatiale internationale en a 400
km d'altitude
ça tombe très vite et donc on est
alternance jour/nuit toutes les 90
minutes toutes les autres toutes les
heures et demie et là ça fait maintenant
une bonne demi heure qui sont du côté
nuit donc donc d'ici le des millières -
samoa que sa main dans un quart d'heure
il devrait évidemment on devrait avoir
des rayons de soleil et les images un
peu plus belles armes on voit là on voit
le lever de soleil sur le fond de
thérèse car c'est magnifique magnifique
qui va commencer à illuminer les
astronautes et les panneaux solaires et
du coup j'imagine qu'ils peuvent plus
vraiment travaillé sur les panneaux
solaires une fois que qui sont en plein
jour alors en fait une phase de la
sortie
qui est prévue pour se dérouler la nuit
c'est la fin de la mission ce sera
plutôt dans deux trois heures on voit
les panneaux solaires et les deux
grossières que vous voyez là les rotules
à droite thomas pesquet à gauche avec
les bandes rouges qui marque que qu'il a
le scaphandre 1 à cette sortie oui quand
on branche qu'ont fait les branchements
électriques des panneaux solaires
il faut que ça se passera du côté nuit
pour éviter que les panneaux solaires
soit en pleine charge et que et qui ait
du courant qui partent dans les câbles
mais là on a essayé on est au soler nous
c'est magnifique on voit thomas pesquet
qui flottent il a autour de la taille
quelques outils qui sont accrochés il à
sa ligne de survie qu'il accroche en
permanence et là c'est à la station
à tout moment qui se déplacent fo qui
sera accrochée donc il a toujours des
mousquetons avec des lignes de vie voilà
le but de la manoeuvre en ce moment
c'est de décrocher et de débloquer ces
gros si l'homme qu'on voit en fait ces
dessins peut-être d'histoire roulant il
sort ce que sont l'état ne soit sur les
panneaux solaires là ils sont enroulés
faut prendre le moins de place possible
une fois qu'ils seront installés ils
vont se dérouler et faire de 20 mètres
de long et c'est quelque chose d'immense
qui va produire 2 avec lester pour la
station merci d'être avec nous si vous
nous rejoignez je vous explique ce que
vous êtes en train de voir tout ce que
vous êtes en train de voir en direct sur
ces images sur figaro live c'est la
troisième sortie dans l'espace de
l'astronaute français thomas pesquet qui
est en train de remplacer des panneaux
solaires sur la station spatiale
internationale bonjour à tous dans le
chatt n'hésitez pas à nous poser des
questions nous allons y répondre en
direct je vais vous lire dans le chat
dont jours à baptiste neveu attached
world à monsieur amaar cause et à sylvie
sylvie qui donne un commentaires
d'encouragement à thomas pesquet respect
à thomas pourvu que tout se passe bien
cyril d'ailleurs quels sont les
principaux risques de cette mission
alors en fait là c'est une sortie en
scaphandre donc on sort de la bri la
station et donc c'est on prend un risque
en fait les risques sont nombreux ces
cons et ont dépendu en oxygène en
électricité et en eau régulation
thermique donc la chaleur de son corps
delà du scaphandre
donc il est il est en autonomie et s'il
ya un problème il faut qu'il puisse
rentrer dans la station donc ça c'est le
premier danger le deuxième danger c'est
je pense qu'ils ne crois pas trop mais
c'est une réalité quand même c'est le
risque de collision avec un micro débris
on sait que en orbite terrestre ya pas
mal de débris et une collision entre un
scaphandre
d'astronautes en train de sortir comme
ça dans l'espace ce serait pas joli du
tout avoir et c'est déjà arrivé s'est
jamais arrivé heureusement les risques
sont très faibles mais ils sont pas
complètement nul il ya eu il ya deux
semaines la nasa a découvert sur un des
bras robotique de la station donc ça en
fait c'est des énormes grues un peu plus
complexe que des grues mais c'est l'idée
c'est un un grand bras articulé qui
permet de manipuler les objets on va le
voir plus tard tenir thomas pesquet et
lui permet de déplacer les panneaux
solaires ce grand brun robotique
on a perçu un impact dans la une
couverture en textile qui recouvre ce se
marre et il ya vu un impact ou par un
débris débris et on imagine ce qui est
ce que ça fait sur un scaphandre
heureusement le lot n'a pas été
endommagé mais c'est un risque très réel
donc une chaque sortie dans l'espace on
a fait pas pour rien
lassine c'est une tâche qui est vraiment
indispensable qui est de changer ses
panneaux solaires pas là puisque changé
c'est en mètres de nouveau sur les
anciens ces panneaux solaires ils ont
été montés par des navettes spatiales
fin des années 90 mis en service en 2000
donc il ya déjà plus de 20 ans la
station est vieille et c'est pas des
panneaux solaires existants ils ont
perdu en capacité et surtout aujourd'hui
avec les progrès on sait faire des
panneaux plus petits plus compact qui
produisent autant d'énergie donc là on
va rajouter une couche de panneaux
solaires devant les anciens il ça va
redonner une nouvelle vie à cette
situation parce que l'énergie c'est
l'électricité c'est indispensable pour
les pour la science pour toutes les
opérations ou encore la caméra de
casques de thomas pesquet avec ses très
belles images sur le fond de globes
terrestres avec le lever de soleil
bonjour saugnac amis bonjour bonjour à
tous sonia qui nous rejoint dans le
tchat sur la page youtube du figaro et
qui nous dit bonjour bravo à thomas
pesquet et qui dit là là là c'est
vraiment impressionnant comme image
effectivement les images que vous voyez
sont donc en direct ça se passe en ce
moment dans la station spécial spatiale
internationale on voit le lever du jour
après avoir passé donc une heure un peu
moins d'une un peu moins d'une heure
complètement dans le noir et envoyait
envoyé son image précédentes on voyait
les anciens le bas des anciens panneaux
solaires qui sont gigantesques
alors là on voit de nouveau thomas
pesquet à l'image facile à reconnaître
avec les bandes rouges devront
scaphandre l'américain shane kim bros
qui l'accompagnent lille à un scaphandre
complètement blanc sans bandes blanches
sans bandes rouges pardon et c'est une
fierté d'ailleurs je pense que pour
thomas pesquet parce qu'il avait le
numéro un et ça change des scaphandres
numéro un c'est à dire c'est le premier
à sortir du sas c'est lui qui donne
l'initiative est qui qui dirige cette
sortie donc c'est aussi encore une fois
une belle de combelles preuve de
confiance par la nasa
c'est un peu le chef de cette mission du
coup y'a pas il n'y a pas de chef
désigné mais le fait qu'ils sortent en
premier et qui sont les derniers à
rentrer c'est lui le leader dans la
sortie et c'est lui qui va réaliser les
tâches les plus critiques notamment
porté les panneaux solaires pour les
installer on voit ces images de son
fonds de terre c'est magnifique c'est
vraiment sublime donc thomas pesquet on
voit il a dans sa main droite là un
support c'est un support qui balle qui
va fixer
sur le bord de la palette et sur lequel
il passe il va se tenir entre soi sa
perceuse c'est sa vie cependant on
dirait un gros outils oui c'est sa vie
sauvage c'est ça vicieuse avec un grand
avec une extension qui permet d'aller
dalle est tombé légiste un peu dans les
coins et difficile d'accès est alors
question un petit peu naïve comme enfin
comment ils font pour que les outils ne
ne partent pas en fait ils sont ils sont
il a autour de la taille
un peu comme un interniste siens il a un
porte outils mais toutes ces outils sont
toujours à toucher attaché à lui-même et
ses aimanté mais non c'est parti c'est
vraiment un petit câble qu'il retient sa
ceinture on voit on voit là ces lignes
de vie qui sont en bas avec un enrouleur
et on voit qu'il a plusieurs objets qui
les quittent kippa qui flottent
librement autour de sa taille et qui
sont honnis par les petits câbles il a
il a fixé sur le côté ça visseuse on la
voit avec le grand tube là c'est comme
une forme de pistolet et là on repasse
sur une vue de la salle de contrôle
s'est beaucoup moins spectacle est aussi
beaucoup moins intéressant mais ça j'en
profite du coup pour vous poser une
question syrie il ya beaucoup de monde
dans le chat de notre page youtube
nicolas hernandez notamment nous
demandait ce qu'on sait combien de temps
va durer cette mission de sortie dans
l'espace pour thomas alors elle est
prévu pour durer six heures et demie
c'est une durée assez assez normal pour
une sortie en scaphandre dire que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure une sortie en
scaphandre c'est pas anodin c'est
vraiment quelque chose de qui se
répètent qui ce travail qui est qu'ils
ont et qu'on ne le fait que pour des
tâches indispensables
c'est dangereux c'est c'est épuisant
aussi physiquement c'était c'est très
très exigeant
thomas pesquet est en pleine forme ok
pas de souci mais cette sortie va durer
six heures et demie pour maximiser les
opérations qu'ils ont à faire
donc il le but de la mission c'est de
fixer cette paire de panneaux solaires
et dimanche aura une deuxième sortie
pour aller fixer une deuxième paire sur
la partie inférieure de valence
de la station et comment ils ont estimé
ce durée de six heures et demie c'est
par rapport aux précédentes missions ou
comment il arrive à estimer en fait la
mission la mission que réalise thomas
pesquet
avec avec shane kim euros elle est l a
complètement intégralement été réalisé à
l'entraînement dans une piscine au
centre spatial johnson dans texas c'est
à houston est en fait ont ils savent à
peu pissas enfin disons une très très
bonne expérience de du temps que prend
chaque opération
le délai déplacements pendant qu'on a vu
on a vu un peu l'art l'harnachement
qu'il avait les lignes de vie se
déplacer autour de la station c'est
quelque chose de compliqué la station
est grande elle fait plus de 2 100
mètres de large
donc là on est on est à l'extrémité du
bras au qui porte les panneaux solaires
donc on est vraiment très très loin de
la zone de vie où se trouvent les
astronautes habituellement donc on est
loin du ca sont les déplacements
prennent du temps et tout ça tout ça est
compté et est donc en fait la nasa
minute par minute un tas une feuille de
dérouler de la mission et ils savent à
houston ils savent exactement s'il est
en avance ou en retard sur le programme
son planning en direct de cette mission
justement de cette sortie dans l'espace
c'est la caméra du casque de thomas
pesquet on le voit il en train de régler
enfin des réglages sur sa vie ce ils
règlent en fait la fois le couple donc
la force avec lesquels il va dévisser et
la vitesse donc ça c'est les réglages
que lui donne
la correspondante qui est une astronaute
qui est au centre keita au texas et qui
elle qui est celle qui est en liaison
radio avec avec les deux astronautes qui
sont en sortie et c'est une astronaute
qui est qui qui a déjà fait une sortie
dans l'espace qui sait comment ça se
passe et qui comprend ce que fait thomas
pesquet et qui vous ont acquis le guide
qu'il donne qui à l affiche de route le
plan le déroulé toute la mission là et
donc à lui dit voilà à thomas ce
prochain boulons il va falloir le faire
douze tours dans le sens contraire des
aiguilles d'une montre
le dévissé avec telle ou telle force et
telle vitesse et donc thomas ils
appliquent les réglages sur sa vie se
faisait donc c'est vraiment du bricolage
alors c'est vous voyez à la vue la vue
je pense que thomas pesquet n'a pas le
temps de regarder la vue mais c'est
quand même
il la voit tous les jours aussi il la
voit tous les jours mais le fait d'être
en scaphandre alors voilà on voit les
panneaux solaires donc là c'est la casse
des caméras de casques de chêne qui mme
brault qui s'est rapproché de l'endroit
où ils vont installer les nouveaux
panneaux solaires on voit les anciens
derrière en arrière-plan et en fait la
wii le fait d'être en scaphandre de
flotter dans ce dans ce vide spatial
avec juste sa visière qui vous sépare du
vide c'est tous les astronautes de l'iss
a rien à voir avec le fait d'être dans
la station bien à l'abri diallo show en
tee shirt et de regarder la terre
évidemment c'est pas les mêmes
sensations et ils ont tous racontent
tous que la première sortie quand on
ouvre le sas et qu'on voit la terre en
dessous il y en a plusieurs qui ont aidé
sentiment de vertige papillon qu'il a
fallu un peu sortir bannu a regardé ces
images on ressent également le même
vertige c'est prendre et adeline ya les
images sont sublimes superbe
bonjour à tous ceux dans le dans le
chatt ya sonia camille qui nous a
rejoint bonjour sonia et sylvie qui pose
une question pour vous cyril qui
demandent si thomas
pesqué va être épuisé à la fin de cette
mission oui ça fait aucun doute
quand on confond quand on parle aux
astronautes qui ont qui ont eu la chance
de faire ce type de sortie dans l'espace
physiquement c'est épuisant
en fait ils sont donc sa bio ça dure au
minimum six heures et demie ça peut
durer un peu plus longtemps s'il ya un
problème
donc ils seront en autonomie avec
oxygène mais il a juste comme comme râle
tellement il a juste un peu d'eau si la
soif
il ya donc physiquement c'est très dur
parce que il faut imaginer on vous avez
peut-être vu de son les images de 115
qu'il a des gants qui sont protégés qui
ont plusieurs couches de protection et
c'est un peu comme on imaginer essayer
de faire du bricolage avec 3 3 paires de
gants de ski sur les doigts c'est pas
facile à manipuler et il ya une vraie
résistance donc il faut une on dit qu'un
bon astronautes pour faire une sortie en
scaphandre il faut qu'ils soient très
forts des avant bras pour être capable
de manipuler les objets sur une longue
durée
ce sont sans crampes sent donc donc les
ja il ya une dimension physique qui est
qui et qui est indéniable
il ya la concentration qui doit être
totale pendant une durée qui finalement
quand même vraiment longue 6h30 c'est
pas rien les gestes faits thomas sur
terre sont hyper simple mais dans
l'environnement où il est en apesanteur
avec un risque permanent avec
l'obligation de penser à chaque fois à
s'attacher à la station et puis là il ay
là il n'a pas le droit de lâcher un
homme a faim il peut pas lâcher dans
l'espace laissé tomber quelque chose
tombe et c'est le mauvais mot mais il
faut il faut que en fait que tous les
gestes soient précis soit réfléchi et
c'est une tension permanente en fait
c'est surtout l'aspect stressant en fait
qui épuise peut-être les deux
il ya là il faut quand même de la force
qu'ils il faut de la force physique et
de l'endurance pour pour se bouger pour
on voit en fait les légendes de thomas
et le flottent dans l'espace qu'elles ne
servent à rien donc tout se fait avec
les bras à la fois les manipulations
fine on voit là les gants de chêne qui
me regardent et ses gants ils sont ils
sont assez encombrant et rien que les
plier pour saisir quelque chose c'est un
effort donc il ya un effort pour se
déplacer ça c'est les avant moi qui font
le travail
et puis oui le stress et la tension qui
sont permanents avec des variations de
températures qui sont importants parce
qu'on passe nous on l'a vu tout à
l'heure de presqu'instantanément du
soleil de la nuit au soleil et du soleil
à la nuit donc heureusement qu'il ya un
scaphandre un système qui régule la
température parce que on passe de grands
gros de -50 à plus 100 degrés sonia
camille qui fait une belle comparaison
c'est comme si il jouait du piano avec
ses gants de boxe c'est un peu ça c'est
ça c'est joué jouait du piano et où
faire la mécanique de précision enfin
c'est on ne sait pas si les bricoleurs
dans le ce qui le regarde mais plus le
plus qu'on fait et minutieux - enfin
être être encombré être je sais c'est
compliqué il a il ya une vision qui est
pas complètement parfaite parce qu'il a
un casque qui est très encombrant donc
il a un champ de vision qui réduit il
peut pas voir il peut pas voir
assez facilement et ses pieds des choses
comme ça donc toutes ces contraintes la
elles font que le travail un travail qui
serait facile sur terre devient vraiment
compliqué et demandé une application
permanente en orbite et ça c'est bateau
thomas pagès pesquié précédent de sortie
en 2017 il avait fait le fait le travail
de manière vraiment vraiment admirable
je crois qu'on a perdu le flux oui on a
perdu le flux mais je ne bougeais pas en
fait c'est la nasa qui doit être en
train de switcher je ne sais quoi mais
on reviendra tout de suite avec avec les
images qu'on va pouvoir trouver donc sur
leflux de la nasa en direct qui continue
donc il ya aucun problème on va vous
réglez ça tout de suite
en attendant je salue tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent dans le chatt notamment
alexandre le bihan recause et sonia
camille qui nous félicite pour ce live
sylvie qui dit également merci à figaro
live de nous faire vivre cette mission
en direct et bien pas de quoi airs cause
félicitations aux journalistes les
explications sont très bonnes bravo et
bien de rien si cela vous plaît
nous allons continuer dans un instant
nous allons retrouver les images en
direct depuis la nasa c'est la nasa qui
va nous les fournir
et j'ai une question d'alexandre le
bihan en attendant qu'ils nous demandent
la vitesse est incroyable et qui nous
pousse cette question comment se fait-il
que l'on ait l'impression que les ss
aille aussi vite
est-ce que c'est dû à la vitesse de la
rotation de la terre ben un peu la
pression elle est pas fausse la station
elle va très vite elle et elle est en
orbite elle tourne autour de la terre à
400 km d'altitude
elle elle avance à 27 milles kilomètres
heure oui et donc c'est cette vitesse là
il fait le tour de la terre en 90
minutes
donc si vous avez cette sensation de
vitesse cela elle l est pas fausse mais
elle est vraiment elle est réelle en
revanche thomas pesquet il est accroché
la station donc celui sa vitesse elle et
c'est celle de la station il va pas plus
vite ni moins vite que la station donc
on peut peut-être arnott retrouver les
faits on voit les la caméra de casques
de masques et on a expliqué tout à
l'heure il a villa sa vie ce en main on
avait aussi une petite vidéo pour
expliquer le parcours de thomas pasquet
tafer sur la station pendant cette
sortie si vous nous rejoignez c'est
l'occasion va vous montrer on va vous
expliquer un peu l'objectif de cette
mission
on a une vidéo de présentation de
fournies par la nasa qui qui est une
petite animation en accéléré de cette
mission qui dure normalement 6h30
ryad qui est à la régie va vous va vous
la lancez derrière nous et puis cyril
pourra vous la commenter dans quelques
instants qui la voit si cette
coopération va voi exe 2 2 heures thomas
pesquet skaff en numéro 1 avec les
bandes rouge et accompagnée de shane kim
bros l'américain son coéquipier de 2017
avec il avait déjà fait deux sorties
dans l'espace
il faut sortir de la zone de vie prend
les outils et se diriger vers les
l'endroit où se trouvent les panneaux
solaires donc tout l'extrémité de la
station et on arrive sur une plateforme
mobile qui est en fait un petit chariot
sur rails et sur lequel sont les laisse
gros cylindre bleu ces nouveaux panneaux
solaires et c'est ça qui va être qu'il
va falloir être installé au dessus des
anciens qu'on voit en arrière plan en
fait c'est comme des stores déroulant et
donc ces deux cylindres voilà on les
voit installé mise à poste
ils vont être après déroulait donc à
chaque fois qu'on voit la visseuse
cesser les opérations qui a effectué ces
branchements vis et c'est la connexion
connecter les câbles électriques aux
anciens panneaux solaires il faut
s'assurer que tout ça soit fait
correctement les lélés on voit la phase
en fait la phase la plus critique c'est
là c'est la fin c'est là c'est ce qu'on
voit maintenant c'est au moment où on va
où thomas pasquet va dérouler les
panneaux et l'a6 à ce bloc c'est un peu
oui
alors là s'est accélérée donc on avec
zéro défaut donc voilà il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas de donc ça c'est x extrêmement
accéléré chaque action individuelle en
fait
elle prend vraiment on l'a vu tout à
l'heure à la moindre action très lent
pour pour dévisser un boulon ça peut
prendre jusqu'à jusqu'à plusieurs
minutes en fait le temps de régler
louloute issa vicieuse de s'assurer que
tout s'est bien accroché que qu'il était
en bonne position qu'il a un bon point
d'appui parce que s'ils commencent à
visser et qui n'est pas accroché la
station séduit c'est thomas pesquet qui
va commencer à tourner et pas là et pas
les crocs donc qui a faim le c'est du
bricolage mais dans des conditions assez
rude assez difficile oui on va revenir
au direct aux images en direct de
fournies par la nasa et on revoit les
donc la caméra du casque de chêne qui
m'auront le coéquipier thomas pesquet
qui est lui qui est donc au à la base
des taux des panneaux solaires
il est il est en fait sur le à côté du
support métallique qui va accueillir les
gros s'ils en bleu qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure la cela sur l'animation en vue
3d
ces cylindres que ce que sont en train
de préparer
thomas pesquet et c'est thomas pesquet
qui va faire l'opération
vraiment vraiment périlleuse de
d'attraper les cylindres ils font 4
mètres cinquante de long et 1300 kg ils
valent ils valent et il va les prendre
les tenir il est déroulée et il fera les
pieds fixé au bras robotique de la
station qui elle va se déplacer et va
déplacer thomas pesquet portant les
styles les panneaux vers l'endroit ils
vont être accrochés
donc ça va être si on a des images de
cette de cette partie de cette partie là
ça va être vraiment spectaculaire et ces
images là seront en direct ce soir donc
j'imagine c'est la dernière étape c'est
le milieu la sortie parce que c'est une
fois qu'ils ont déplacé le panneau il ya
encore pas mal de choses à faire donc
c'est pas sinon cela il en train de les
préparer là il en train de le relâcher
câblé de renault il entrain de relâcher
les dernières attaches qui accroche les
panneaux solaires au la plateforme on
voit une palette un peu blanche qui cas
qui nous cachent thomas pesquet c'est le
support mobile sur lequel on les
panneaux solaires avaient été accrochés
il faut les décrocher de sa les
transporter et après les raccrocher à la
station alors ils sont deux dans
l'espace actuellement donc il ya thomas
pesquet et puis son coéquipier
l'américain shane kim ho c'est ça est-ce
qu'il ya l'un des deux qui a un rôle un
poste de validateurs de vérificateur
pour voir que tout est bien câbles et où
ils font tous les deux dans leur mission
dans leurs cours ils ont tous les deux
des tâches
vraiment séparés et ils font ils font
chacun les tâches qui sont
complémentaires et en fait on entend de
temps en temps thomas pesquet
poser des questions à chaîne qui
brouille les shame ça y est ce que tu as
fini telle opération
donc il se tient au courant de ce que
fait son coéquipier pour savoir s'il lui
est en avance ou en retard il faut
qu'ils se coordonnent il faut que ça que
ça marche ensemble on le voit on voit
thomas pesquet magnifiques images sur
fond de terre c'est vraiment
spectaculaire je pense que thomas
puisqu'elle a pas le temps de me voir le
paysage et d'en profiter mais il le fera
certainement en fin de mission une fois
qu'il aura réussi à accrocher les
panneaux solaires c'est à ce moment là
fait qu'ils ceux qui seront c'est que
les internautes eux prennent le temps de
profiter de la vue profiter de ce moment
exceptionnel qui est qu'il est en train
de vivre parce que c'est sa troisième
sortie dans l'espace
il en a une quatrième prévu dimanche
c'est vraiment des temps forts de sa
carrière ça va rester c'est sûr c'est
pas me laisser ses souvenirs les plus
forts avec les décollages en fusée qui
sont des moments incroyables
et voilà donc là il en train de vivre
quelque chose de très très fort il est
je pense qu'il est hyper concentré donc
il il est pas dans l'émotion il n'est
pas du tout alors là on est en train
d'attraper un accroche pied c'est hyper
important c'est pas spectaculaire mais
c'est le support qu'il va accrocher ses
chaussures pour pouvoir être tenus par
le bras robotique et et tenir lui-même à
bout de bras les panneaux solaires
toujours l'idée que comme celui qui
s'accroche lui même sur les accroches
oui oui
l'idée c'est qu'il faut des points
d'appui sinon quand on fait en
apesanteur on peut pas exercer de de
force
là il se déplace on voit les on voit les
poignets qui sont dorés les parties
d'oreillons qui sont qui sont sur la
station c'est les poignées c'est fait
pour s'accrocher tout le reste on n'y
touche pas c'est il ya les codes
couleurs en fait la station est quand
même complexe très complexe on voit
beaucoup de choses qui dépassent les ses
éléments doré cesser les points l'appui
sur lequel les astronautes ont le droit
de s'accrocher et doivent s'accrocher
même parce que donc c'est à la fois les
endroits où on s'accroche à une de vie
on voit là où on le voit mousquetons hop
c'est un local de l'escaladé on
s'accroche à 5 vraiment des procédures
d'escaladé avec l'idée qu'il a il a deux
de ligne de vie
deux mousquetons indépendant il doit
toujours en avoir une accrocher la
station ont fait la même jour ma manière
un peu moins spectaculaire en
accrobranche c'est quelque chose qu'on a
mise en fait de la tyrolienne
mais c'est vraiment cette logique là et
c'est les mousquetons c'est les
mousquetons pas très loin de ce qu'on en
escaladant et la ligne de vie elle fait
combien de mètres avant alors il a il a
deux lignes de vie et il y en a une
belle qui est un kit assez extensible
parce qu'elle a un enrouleur j'ai pas la
longueur exacte mais c'est que c'est
quelqu'un qui s'enroule comme une laisse
de chien oui c'est ça ouais
et dans le cas où une fausse manip ou
problème ils se décrochent thomas
pesquet pas et paco est pas perdu parce
que j'ai pas si les gens qui ont vu
gravity le film catastrophe en orbite
bien sûr je pense toujours à ça quand on
envoie ses sorties dans les ca peut
arriver c'est s'est heureusement jamais
arrivé un astronaute en scaphandre
depuis les débuts de la conquête
spatiale
mais ça peut arriver et dans ce cas là
thomas pesquet a une chance de s'en
sortir parce qu'il a sur son sur son sac
à dos un équivalent 20h de jetpack donc
des tout petits propulseurs qui peut
commander et qui peuvent l'aider à
rejoindre et se rapprocher de la station
qui enfin le jetpack et dirigeables et
il a accroché un endroit sont
son scaphandre et la partie qu'il a dans
le dos qui essaient oxygène et batteries
pour les pôles énergie et alors là on
voit sonia camille qui répondent oui on
a bien vu gravity on l'a vu ça fait on
l'a tous vu et j'ai d'ailleurs une
question de nicolas hernandez qui nous
posait un petit peu plus haut dans le
chat qui vous demandent cyril que vont
ils faire des anciens panneaux solaires
health qui sont laissés dehors pour se
perdre dans l'espace os qui sont rentrés
pour faire partie des déchets à évacuer
alors c'est une très bonne question en
fait ils vont pas les remplacer j'ai
peut-être mal et tu es un mois et
adéquate ils vont pas remplacer les
panneaux solaires ils vont en rajouter
en fait les nouveaux panneaux solaires
vont être fixés devant les anciens qui
reste en place et qui même s'ils sont un
peu moins performants ils ont été au
soleil depuis 20 ans ils ont été aussi
bombardé par des micros débris ils ont
perdu deux perdu en performance mais ils
sont encore efficaces ce qui fonde isolé
christ est aujourd'hui la station donc
ils resteront à l'activation activités
d'e on et ils vont juste un petit peu
caché par les nouveaux panneaux solaires
qui sont un peu plus compact plus souple
et plus léger mais il reste son
fonctionnement on va passer on va choix
qu'on va passer de
cent vingt mille boîtes à a presque
presque le double avec nos nouveaux
panneaux solaires donc c'est pour le le
gain en énergie avoir de la station va
être énorme et c'est intéressant que ça
permet de faire de la science plus
d'expérience en même temps l'expérience
plus énergivores et puis surtout en ce
moment il ya quand même sept astronautes
à bord de la station donc ça c'est des
besoins en énergie qui sont importants
c'est oui je me demandais d'ailleurs
donc pendant cette mission ils sont
épaulés par des une équipe qui est sur
terre oui et oui à la fois dans les sss
qui est alors en fait le whale le
contrôle le plus important pour cette
pour cette partie de la mission c'est le
centre spatial à houston de la nasa
qu'avec le on a vu toute la salle de
contrôle
mais ils sont ils sont surveillés aussi
par les astronautes qui sont à bord de
la station
c'est eux qui les ont aidés à se
préparer à mettre leur scaphandre et
encore une différence avec gravity en
scaphandre ça se met pas en cinq minutes
hier la préparation et la phase 2
d'habillage de thomas pesquet a pris
plusieurs heures
donc ça c'est les astronautes qui sont à
bord parce que c'est lourd ou pourquoi
parce que c'est compliqué en apesanteur
c'est très encombrant en fait il ya
aussi plusieurs il ya plusieurs sous
couche il a on le voit pas mais il ya il
ya les verts c'est pas très sympa très
sexy mais il a un sous vêtements
thermiques qui est une genre de
combinaison interne dans lequel il est
tout petit tuyau qui font circuler de
l'eau et qui permettent de garder ça le
corps à température
là on voit on voit on voit là seront
classés pas de bordeaux je pense que ces
chaînes guillemot c'est l'amérique de
moeurs et s était pas ce qu'était cette
position là donc je suis un peu surpris
la fastkey tôt face au soleil et à plus
100 degrés est coté à l'ombre du
scaphandre et lui à moins 50
donc il ya une variation et son
température importante et c'est pour ça
lui fait circuler de l'eau pour garder
le corps de l'astronaute à température
vraiment constante et éviter des coups
de chaud les coups de froid et donc
l'habillage et non le scaphandrier hyper
en combat envoyés en voit la taille que
ça prend il est là ce que le scaphandre
américain il en deux parties il ya les
jambes
et puis elle a toute la partie haute
donc il faut ce vraiment se glisser
dedans et on peut pas le faire tout seul
en fait on peut pas le faire tout seul
il ya toute une partie de préparation je
parlais du jetpack pour en cas de soucis
pour se déplacer il a accroché un
scaphandre une fois que l'astronaute et
dans le scaphandre on peut pas le faire
tout seul trou donc on peut pas faire
deux sorties dans l'espace dans l'espace
si on n'est pas celle assistés par des
astronautes qui sont qui sont à bord si
vous nous rejoignez merci merci beaucoup
vous regardez ces images en direct avec
nous depuis donc les images sont en
direct depuis la station internationale
spatiale pardon et il s'agit d'une
sortie en espace de thomas pesquet et de
son coéquipier américain shane kim ho
qui viennent remplacer enfin rajouté des
panneaux solaires sur les panneaux
solaires existants de l' iss merci à
ceux qui nous rejoindront le chat sur
notre page youtube à au minium à
patriotes à will it injuste et roxanne
chapelle qui nous dit quelle chance avec
un coeur viol et effectivement il a
beaucoup de chance mais je ne sais pas
si en ce moment ils regardent beaucoup
la terre je pense qu'il est plutôt
concentré sur ce qu'il doit faire
alors lol marque lol man rtm nous
demandent combien vont-ils en m de
panneaux solaires j'imagine
et combien il y en aura-t-il au total et
j'ai une deuxième question qui qui suit
sur ces panneaux solaires de au minium
qui nous demande qui a fabriqué ces
panneaux solaires est ce qu on le sait
syrie alors très bonne question il ya
huit pairs aujourd'hui 2
de grands panneaux solaires qui avaient
été apportées par des navettes spatiales
américaines fin des années 90 début des
années 2000 donc au tout début la
station le premier aimant la session il
arrive en 98 ces panneaux solaires est
arrivé un petit peu plus tard les
nouveaux panneaux solaires ils ont été
conçus en californie par une société
dont j'ai oublié le nom mais c'est un
vrai c'est un vrai projet de la nasa
menée en interne en fait la partie la
plus complexe et panneaux ce n'est pas
c'est pas les panneaux eux mêmes c'est
pas la partie qui fournit l'électricité
ça c'est quelque chose que qui est assez
standard entre guillemets dans le on
connaît ça dans le spatial depuis
longtemps et c'est le dispositif qui
permet de les étendre
on le voit là on voit ces listes il sait
les cylindres qu'on voit à l'image c'est
la première fois que ce mécanisme est
employé oui c'est la révolution
il a été testé il ya il ya trois ans
sous forme un peu un peu réduite à bord
de la station et la nasa avait réussi le
test a trouvé que c'était très réussi
donc c'est panneaux déroulants vont
voilà ils sont ils ont été conçus par la
nasa ils sont le système en fait il faut
il faut qu'à la fois le déploiement soit
parfait il faut aussi que ça
maintiennent le panneau dans une forme
qui soit assez rigide il faut pas que ça
bouge on le voit derrière nous la
station c'est quelque chose d'immense ça
fait plus
plus de cent mètres de large c'est plus
que deux fois la surface d'un terrain de
foot
donc on imagine que quand ça se déplace
il il faut pas que ça bouge trop faut
pas que ça soit souple comme un
marshmallow donc il ya des contraintes à
la foi en eux régis dit et et de
légèreté tout ce qu'on en voit dans
l'espace il faut que ça soit léger
l'aller
chaque paire de cylindres qu'on voit à
l'écran là devant chez nkembo ils font
1300 kg donc c'est par ben oui ça fait
ressenti de combien de kilos on appela
le bas thomas pesquet il va on le voit
là il en train de s'installer au bout du
bras robotisé canadien avec voilier les
drapeaux canada dessus donc ça c'est le
c'est ça qui va le déplacer il est lille
a les pieds je crois enfin je suis
passionné j'aime autant qu'il avait là
il a les pieds en l'air il a la tête en
battant bâle et pire lien les choix
qu'ils en train de s'accrocher les pieds
au support qui est au bout du bras ou
alors non il n'a pas encore les pieds
fixé mais ça va pas ça devrait pas
tarder et ça se fixe comment d'ailleurs
on le sait s'il a des cale-pieds
d'accord connaît pas le détail et comme
les chaussures de ski peut-être c'est
vrai que des grosses chaussures mais le
mécanisme est assez simple il a il a
aussi un moyen de d'orienter le cale
pieds lui-même et donc il a un peu
d'autonomie sur la manière dont ils ont
il s'en sert c'est ce gros bras
robotiques la ce
cette grue qui avait été impacté par un
fragment de débris spatial il ya
quelques semaines et qui avait fait une
frayeur et la nasa donc c'est aussi ça
fait partie aussi de danger de cette
sortie dans l'espace c'est que il est en
scaphandre voulez quand même pas très
protégé contre ce qui peut le ce qui
peut lui arriver l'extérieur n'est donc
si thomas pesquet va s'installer au bout
de ce bar c'est pour ce jeu revient jeu
pour saisir déroulée après non il va pas
l'aider rouler ils valent il va d'abord
les porter ils font 1300 kg mais comme
il y en aura pas en tort ils n'ont pas
de ils n'ont pas de poids ils ont une
masse qui reste qu'une 300 kilos ils
n'ont pas demain ils n'ont pas de poids
donc il peut les prendre et les
manipuler ils ont juste de l'inertie
l'idée c'est que quand on fait glisser
quelque chose de lourd sur une patinoire
imaginons poussins frigo sur la
patinoire au début c'est un peu
difficile puis une fois qu'on a commencé
à pousser ça glisse ça glisse ça glisse
puis quand on veut arrêter et bien là il
faut lutter contre l'inertie donc le
poids de l'objet qu'on a poussé qu'on a
mis en mouvement il faut l'arrêter
et bien c'est pareil avec ce qui va
porter donc il n'aura pas de mal à
manipuler 1300 kg en revanche que le
mouvement va s'arrêter
il va ressentir cette inertie il va
ressentir le fait fort rapide elles
pourront donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
qu'il soit bien accroché par les pieds
au bras robotique de la station donc ses
bras robotique ne servent pas forcément
à l'aider à porter mais plutôt à l'aider
à s'arrêter
les avants y voit yvon ils vont l'aider
à soyons l'aider à se déplacer parce que
il a besoin de points d'appui pour
pouvoir porter aussi ces objets oui
c'est toujours la même idée on est dans
la pesanteur c'est comme quand vous êtes
dans un plongeon dans une piscine
si vous aussi vous toucher quelque chose
sans être accroché vous allez tourner
vous avez tourné autour de l'objet et
moi c'est un peu pareil avec le avec la
avec le
la pesanteur dans ce cas faut il faut il
faut être accroché à quelque chose si on
veut exercer un effort alors il ya
matteo 974 qui nous a rejoints dans le
chat et qui demande de faire un petit
résumé de ce qui s'est passé depuis le
début de cette sortie il ya beaucoup
d'internautes qui nous ont déjà répondu
dans le chatt merci d'ailleurs à mister
urbex à saugnac amis il ya deux textes
de lui répondre
cyril est ce qu'on sait déjà quelles
sont les étapes qui sont déjà passés et
les autres qu'il reste avant
l'installation finale de ce alors là
thomas pesquet ça fait deux heures qu'il
est qu'il est sortie dans l'espace le
temps le temps le point de départ de la
sortie ces moments où ils ouvrent où il
est oui en autonomie dans le scaphandre
et qu'il ouvre le sas donc ça c'était il
ya deux heures et deux heures il est
c'était assez marrant d'ailleurs il
était on était au dessus de la france
ouverture du sas thomas pasquet survol
de la france est sûre je crois pas
peut-être pour faire la photo qui me
fera sur les réseaux sociaux ce soir est
donc là c'est le début de la sortie il
est sorti donc avec shane kim ho c'est
un coéquipier qui connaît bien parce
qu'il a déjà fait deux sorties dans
l'espace en 2017
vous avez pas changer les panneaux il
avait remplacé des batteries il y avait
des batteries parler de la station elle
était vieillissante et une techno
qu'avec été un peu anciennes et il avait
remplacé des batteries plus léger au
lithium
on est habitués on a tous des batteries
au lithium au smartphone avec dans la
station maintenant grâce à thomas
pesquet il ya des batteries plus moderne
et l'appareil et thomas basket on va
faire une cette mission hyper importante
de 2,2 de fournir de l'énergie à des
panneaux solaires qui sont vieillissants
et qui qui arrive qui en fait il y avait
une
ils ont été conçus pour un fou pour
fonctionner 15 ans elle chante le plus
ancien des panneaux a été mis en place
en 2015
on comprend en 2000 pendant 2000
on savait plus de 20 ans on comprend que
il était temps de leur donner un petit
coup de pouce avec les nouveaux panneaux
solaires pour à la fois augmenter
l'énergie de la station et s'assurer que
ça allait pouvoir fonctionner encore
plusieurs années
donc voilà pour en résumé donc là thomas
pesquet a passé pas mal de temps à
préparer les panneaux solaires c'est lé
gros cylindre qu'on voit à l'image là
qui sont devant chez nkembo l'américain
ces grosses cylindrées été fixée pour le
décollage à une capsule dragon de spe 6
ils ont ensuite été fixée sur une
plateforme mobile qui est en forme après
un faux une sorte de petit chariot sur
rail qui peut voyager tout le long de la
structure qui est transversale de la
station qui est qui qui courent d'un
côté à l'autre et qui est utilisé pour
ça pour transporter des charges lourdes
et encombrantes
mais il reste encore une dizaine
quinzaine de mètres à effectuer entre
cette version de mobile
hélas hélas l'endroit finale où ils vont
être installés donc au bout du bras et
c'est qu'elle ces derniers mètres c'est
thomas pesquet au bout du bras robotisé
qui va les tenir à bout de bras et les
amener à poste et son coéquipier va
faire quoi pendant ce temps là alors le
coéquipier il sera lui
du côté du côté non c'est thomas pesquet
convoi en fait j'ai l'impression est ce
que vous voyez des bandes rouges c'est
thomas pesquet voilà comment on peut
l'identifier
sur ces images rouge sur les épaules et
se réjouissent whissell thomas pesquet
là on les voit les bandes rouges les
voit pas bien
peut-être oui peut-être donc c'est un
malheur c'est des plis parce que sean
kimball il est plus lui alain l'endroit
où les panneaux vont arriver donc au
bout du bras
il est en train de préparer l'endroit
ils vont être fixés on voit pas bien les
bandes rouges mais je crois que c'est
thomas pesquet si si on voit les bandes
sous les cuisses là on voit le mieux sur
cette image on voit sa ligne de vie avec
l'enrouleur en bas il est sur un très
beau fond de terre je sais pas au dessus
de où ils sont si les internautes eux
reconnaissent le paysage les côtes
ça c'est un petit jeu très difficile
donc c'est très difficile surtout avec
les langages à 400 km d'altitude avec
les nuages une vitesse de 27 mille
kilomètres heure c'est parce que ça
exactement thomas parce que je pense que
c'est parce qu'on ne sait pas son
objectif
l'objectif c'est de réaliser son travail
avec le plus de soin possible alors il
ya halte kameraden qui nous demandent si
le scaphandre et climatisés oui très
bonne question le scaf on va évidemment
climatisés parce qu'une grosse
différence de température entre le côté
au soleil et le côté à l'ombre au soleil
en a presque à plus de 100 degrés et à à
côté où on est à moins 50
et pourquoi cette énorme varier son jeu
ne s'inquiète pas d'atmosphère donc ya
pas de mélange de la chaleur entre entre
l'ombre et la lumière
donc ça fait des variations thermiques
énorme et donc il à thomas pesquet kom
kom kom kom shenkin broyles à une sous
combinaison avec des tout petits
circuits d'eau qui circulent et qui le
refroidit ou le réchauffe et donc qu'il
maintienne sa température à 37° éviter
qu'il ne transpire éviter qu'ils
surchauffe ou qu'il est trop froid donc
la combinaison est évidemment qu'on
climatisés si vous nous rejoignez ça
fait un peu plus de 45 minutes que nous
sommes en direct pour suivre cette
troisième sortie dans l'espace de thomas
pesquet
qui doit s'affairer à remplacer en tout
cas à rajouter des panneaux solaires sur
la station spatiale internationale nous
sommes en direct avec cyril van
lerberghe qui commente grâce à tout son
savoir ses images n'hésitez pas à poser
toutes vos questions dans le chat du
figaro.fr mme sy sur notre page youtube
où ces images vous sont diffusées en
direct on essaye de répondre à toutes
vos questions
anthony pobl ont d'ailleurs qui nous
rejoint l'instant bonjour nous demande
combien de temps il reste en dehors de
la station la sortie est prévue pour
durer six heures et demie ça peut être
un petit peu plus long ou un peu un peu
plus court en fonction du rythme de
travail des deux donc ça c'est le temps
qu'ont qu'on compte entre moment où ils
ouvrent le sas et où il revient dans le
sas et ils sont et c'est d'ailleurs on
voit qu'on est dans une phase
éclairés en fin de jour tout à l'heure
quand on a démarré le live et nous
étions et on était du côté de nuit qui
était nuit combien de temps il nous
reste encore à un tenir entre guillemets
sûr je crois qu'on va bientôt comtois
c'est du côté nuit parce qu'on a
on fait un tour en fait thomas pasquet
la station font un tour autour de la
terre toutes les en une heure et demie
en 90 minutes
donc on met en acommencé il ya quarante
cinq minutes à pied de nuit donc une
journée ça dure 45 minutes donc on est
on va bientôt passer la nuit et les
images seront peut-être moins
spectaculaire profitez bien de ces
images qui nous parviennent en direct
depuis les ss la station spatiale
internationale sont des images fournies
par la nasa
vous voyez direct et c'est du direct
on commence à bien arrivé un petit peu
dans le noir justement j'ai l'impression
l'astronaute et bien et bien et bien à
l'ombre l'angle du soleil a bien changé
depuis le début' depuis tout à l'heure
alors il ya deux personnes qui ont
répondu à votre votre question à cyril
de savoir est ce que vous savez ce qu'on
survole actuellement à ce qu'enfin que
survolent les ss actuellement élu mister
b acc disait qu'ils étaient au niveau de
la côte africaine de la libye egast qui
nous ne nous disaient qu'on passait
devant l'algérie alors on attaque l'os
est possible et te soigne un très bon
moyen pour savoir c'est un outil qui
s'appelle iss tracker qui est sur
internet est qui et qui montre la
position de la station au dessus de la
terre on dirait temps réel mais pour
elle
merci à ces à merci à ces commentaires
qui nous qui nous explique zekri mousse
ou ans voyage alors gaz se pose une
question que foulée les autres
astronautes qui sont restés eux à
l'intérieur de liesse
alors ils poursuivent leur il y en a il
y en a deux qui sont vraiment consacré
au suivi de ce qui se passe dans la
station dans la sortie c'est ce qu'ils
ont qui ont préparé les scaphandres donc
c'est l'américaine megan
mcandrew je crois et marc vanden à et
qui sont qui sont deux astronautes
américains qui sont à bord et qui ont
aidé thomas pesquet à se mettre en
scaphandre et eux donc ils vont rester
mais je crois que les le reste de
l'équipage donc le japonais qui équipent
commandant de bord en ce moment et les
deux russes n'ont pas forcément de rôle
très précis et cela pendant cette sortie
il pilote les ss alors elle se pilote
tout seul mais il ya des détaillants il
il faut faire de l'activité physique
tous les jours il ya de la recherche
scientifique
les activités ne manquent pas et même si
à cet homme à bord pour faire le travail
mais le contrôle de la mission il est
vraiment effectué à houston au centre
les astronautes tout à fait une salle de
contrôle qui sert et au contrôle des
vols habités et est thomas pesquet et
shane kim bros sont en relation radio
direct avec houston avec une astronaute
qu'est ce qu'on appelle le capcom qui
est qui et le relais radio avec la terre
et killer ne leur donne pas à parler les
tâches à réaliser ce a répondu à la
question de l dans le chat qui nous
demandent si thomas pesquet communique
avec le centre de la nasa sur terre pour
valider les étapes où la distance oui
parce que je crois qu'on survole le nil
là et la mer rouge dans le fond là je
sais tu es
donc c'était bien là donc c'était les
côtes africaines et on a derrière nous
le tracker lier ce tracker merci merci
merci ryad de l'avoir affiché derrière
nous et donc on est bien au dessus de
l'afrique et on se rapproche de la mer
rouge et est vous on voit qu'on arrive
bientôt dans la partie nuit exactement
on se rapproche de la partie nuit donc
les belles images sur fond de terre
c'est bientôt fini alors mais là on
retrouve thomas pesquet alors pourquoi
il est dans le noir
thomas pesquet espace qui n'est pas
parce qu'il ya pas la terre on a
exactement il est payé sur fond de ciel
et donc le ciel même en plein jour il
est noir dans la station internationale
il n'y a pas d'atmosphère manquez pas de
ciel bleu on est sur la caméra de
casques de thomas pesquet je crois et et
on voit il a toujours il a toujours à la
fois les lignes de vie les on voit le
fixe le fixe le marche pied sur lequel
il va s'il va s'installer pour faire
pour pour tenir les piles en train de le
faire des réglages là je crois il a dû
fixer se marchent pieds au bras robotisé
la station il va prendre on voit les
envoie les attaches dans lequel il va
glisser ses pieds c'est un peu comme des
fixations de je ne sais pas si c'est les
chaussures de ski ou de ski nautique
peut-être plus comparable surf plutôt un
et de ski de randonnée
donc il est en train il en train de
préparer son point d'appui et partir
duquel il va il va pouvoir se tenir et
et travailler porter les panneaux
solaires et on voit les pieds de
schengen bros là-bas en arrière-plan qui
lui arrive qu'ils aient flotte en fait
donc là il s'est rapproché du d2 d'aider
les rouleaux qui sont les panneaux
solaires qui vont aller chercher sa la
caméra de casque c'est un peu la seule
vue qu'on a une fois qu'on passe du côté
nuit là on voit un peu je crois le
coucher de soleil un peu en fond de fond
d'image du casque de thomas pesquet on
voit les panneaux solaires qui sont ceux
qui vont être ils vont pas être remplacé
mais ils vont être installés par dessus
tout installé devant mais on voit aussi
des radiateurs qui sont des partis qui
cherchent qui qui servent à évacuer la
chaleur accumulée dans la station
internationale
on voit encore là les pieds du jeune guy
môquet balance sur fond noir blanc sont
noirs sur la caméra de cazaux thomas
pesquet il et il a accroché sa ligne de
vie je crois au support au marché pieds
donc ça veut dire qu'il va bientôt faire
la transition entre le la station non
lissé loin du marchepied la caméra de
casque c'est un peu grand angle ça s'est
passé à 7 et la caméra de castres c'est
principalement pour pour ceux qui sont à
houston exactement exactement égal race
avec cette caméra de casque ils
surveillent ils savent exactement ce
qu'il fait et houston attendait à
période régulière je crois que c'est
toute les 25 minutes demande à chaque
astronaute de faire un check de prendre
le temps de vérifier l'intégrité de sas
à son scaphandre
c'est pour ça que thomas il a des petits
miroirs qui sont fixés à ses poignets je
sais pas ce qu'ils voulaient leye sur
cette image on les voit un peu je crois
bref on va à droite sur son gant ces
miroirs il lui servent à regarder à
vérifier le parti avant de sa soeur de
son scaphandre pour voir s'il n'y a pas
de petit accroc de choses qui ont été
abîmés ils vérifient doit vérifier ses
gants vérifier qui a pas deux pareils de
coupure de choses qui
qui menacerait leur intégrité et c'est
moins fréquent aussi le moment où
l'astronaute coéquipiers fait une
vérification du dos de son coéquipier
mais donc voilà ça passe aussi par la
technologie sont enfin ils sont quand
même dans l'espace et non pas des
combinaisons des scaphandres qui
détecterait une anomalie ou les
scaphandres y sont ils sont conception
assez ancienne ils avaient été conçus
pour la navette spatiale
donc c'est une conception qui date du
début des années 80
ces matériels très fiables certains
escales fin on vraiment plus de plus de
30 ans fin mais il doit vérifier à la
nuque ou s il se compare à couper la
combinaison c'est pas 2 c à la fois du
high tech et la technologie éprouvée
faire que c'est pas un domaine dans
lequel on fait d'andré on a fait
énormément de progrès depuis les
missions apollo dans les années 60 et
les années 70 donc que c'est c'est il ya
des dodgers en français qui a fait
qu'ils ont fait des sorties en
scaphandre et qui disait mais c'est
hallucinant qu'on n'ait pas de moyens
de récupérer l'énergie avec une boisson
sucrée par exemple parce que c'est
physiquement difficile c'est épuisant et
il ya que juste une petite pipette avec
un peu d'eau s'ils ont soif donc il faut
bien manger avant quoi il faut bien
manger avant et pas faire de crise
d'hypoglycémie
une fois dans le scaphandre alors là je
ne sais pas bien ce qu'on voit alors il
ya madame sharp est qu'ils nous
demandent si on peut mettre un petit peu
le son du direct je ne sais pas si c'est
possible pour ryad en régie de mettre un
petit peu le son d'ambiance parce
qu'effectivement ils se parlent entre
eux entre huy houston entre les deux
spationautes qui soutenait on peut on
peut dire sont envoyés coûté avec
écouter avec vous y'a pas toujours le
laisse pas tout le temps parce
qu'effectivement cyril répond à vos
questions mais on peut mettre en en font
un petit peu de son d'ambiance
alors j'imagine qu'ils se parlent pas
tout le temps non plus n'ont hélas on
voit on en convois sont bonnes images on
voit thomas pesquet accent français de
pour apprécier la qualité de l'anglais
de thomas pesquet donc la voix féminine
celle aniston prix donne instruction sur
les habitats chalghoumi est question
dans le chatt justement qui demandait
pourquoi ce sont toujours des hommes qui
sortent de nier c'est pas toujours des
sommes de plus en plus il ya des
instruments
des femmes qui font des sorties en
scaphandre eux
au moment de la mission de thomas
pesquet en 2017 il y avait là des maires
ont demandé qui allait faire des
missions scaphandre et finalement
c'était une femme qui remplaçait thomas
pesquet il a fait que deux hôtesses de
sortie c'était déjà pas mal
dans le camp faire 3 mais nous non il ya
des cas des femmes en scaphandre et
elles se sont un peu battu il ya
quelques années parce qu'il n'y avait
pas assez de scaphandres de petite
taille a donc il ya quand même il
n'avait ainsi pas sur mesure à la faune
non il ya trois tailles de cavale peut
être les moyens et grands et il y avait
beaucoup de médium et de grands et très
peu de petits et les tailles après sont
ajustables
mais quand même donc les femmes disait
attention en existe on n'existe hélas
sont réels sont aussi évidemment aussi
compétentes que les hommes et non elles
font des sorties en scaphandre et il n'y
a aucun je pense que ça fait partie des
paramètres que la nasa est en train de
d'équilibré en fait je demandé ce ratio
hommes femmes dans l'espace donc
toujours thomas pesquet au centre de
l'image ça y est on est dans la nuit on
est dans la nuit on voit j'essaie de
lire images mais c'est pas complètement
facile voit pas grand chose sachant que
nous avons une caméra devant le visage
pour tout vous expliquer pour expliquer
le texte et est en crise et donc on a on
assure le haut de l'image on allait le
bas des panneaux solaires qui vont être
je crois que ça il faut s'est passé pas
si facile que ça à la demi heure
les autres images qu'on a en général
celles et les caméras de casque avec la
petite lampe frontale qui est fixé au
casque de l'astronaute c'est pas
forcément à 6 heures on voit en haut à
gauche de l'image on voit les deux
panneaux solaires par les deux cylindres
qui sont les panneaux solaires qui vont
être déployés et que thomas parce
qu'elle va installer ccc gros tubes qui
font plus de quatre mètres de long et
une fois déployé qui feront plus la
surface un amas court de tennis
c'est ça qui va qui est l'objet du
déplacement et de la sortie alors
maintenant qu'on est dans le noir on
peut peut-être visionner une dernière
fois donc le clip la vidéo de la nasa
qui explique un peu qui schématise en 3d
en accéléré tout cette mission car
matteo 974 nous pose cette question
quelles sont les étapes de
l'installation des panneaux solaires
donc on va pouvoir revenir là dessus en
commentant donc ce clip d'animation
présenté par la nasa du mal à finir ma
fraise donc là on passe bien la phase
demi on le voit sur la grâce au sol on
va survoler dans quelques minutes
l'afrique voilà j'ai deux sentiments
scaphandre le premier à sortir c'était
thomas pesquet avec schengen gros donc
thomas pesquet qu'on reconnaît à l'image
quand il a les bandes rouges sur son
scaphandre
ils ont préparé leurs outils ils sont
allés jusqu'à les deux les cylindres
bleu qu'on voit son image c'est des
cylindres blanc un peu un peu con voyez
tout à l'heure en vrai il ya toute la
phase de préparation
là c'est là l'endroit où les panneaux
vont être installés donc qui on voit les
visseuses les les gestes à faire pour
préparer tout ça c'est pas nous c'est
donc c'est des cylindres c'est comme
dexter roulant déroulant plutôt parce
qu'ils seront déroulés une seule fois on
a manqué il manque une phase importante
c'est la phase où thomas pasquet a les
pieds fixé au bout du bras robotique
il a porté à bout de bras les sea dogs
pour les mettre en plan en situation là
on les voit là ils sont déjà mis en
scylla ils sont déjà mis en situation et
là c'est une fille ils sont en train de
réaliser une phase qui va être réalisée
forcément de nuit enfin de sortie et
pourquoi de nuit c'est parce qu'il faut
que les panneaux solaires soit pas au
soleil quand on les déploie et quand on
les branches donc cette partie là elle
est de toute façon les images ne sont
pas forcément les plus basses de la
sortie voilà les panneaux sondés sont
déroulés ça a été très rapide sur les
sur l'animation ça sera pas aussi en
ôtant havrais la phase est vraiment
critique
ce déploiement qui a déjà été testé il
ya quelques années avec un des panneaux
solaires qui avait la même technologie
mais qui était un peu plus petite taille
et ils vont voir en fait ils vont
arriver devant les anciens panneaux
solaires qui sont bien plus grands ea
est en fête avec une taille plus petite
on a autant d'énergie par panneaux
solaires
donc là ils vont installer la première
paire dimanche thomas pesquet génie
kébreau toujours la même paire ils vont
installer les deux autres sur le même de
l'autre côté côté haut et bas et il
faudra encore quatre autres sorties dans
l'espace par d'autres astronautes pour
placer dont les deux autres deux autres
paires il y aura 6 6 6 nouveaux panneaux
solaires qui vont être installées
au-dessus des 8 existants alors y'a pas
pire 0,03 sur le chat du figaro.fr qui
nous demandent dans combien de temps
verra-t-on le déroulement des nouveaux
panneaux
alors on va retourner tout de suite aux
images en direct pour pour pop 003 il
s'avère c'est dans plusieurs oeuvres
imagine oui en fait ça fait je regarde
ma montre ça fait deux heures vingt qui
sont sortis dans l'espace donc on est on
a à peu près un tiers de la mission de
la sortie dans l'espace donc il faut
encore
la phase la phase qui va vraiment
spectaculaire je pense hélas moment où
thomas pesquet va saisir à bout de bras
c'est cylindres 2 4 mètres cinquante de
long et tout 1300 kg un peu comme
superman il va les porter il en
apesanteur oui c'est thomas pesquet mais
bon c'est pas un miracle et les mettre
en leur position finale
à poste devant les panneaux solaires
existants donc ça je pense que c'est la
phase va plus la plus spectaculaire il
va se dérouler dans les heures qui
viennent
hélas ce qu'on voit on dirait que c'est
le poste de commandement à houston c'est
ça c'est oui c'est la salle de contrôle
donc à houston au texas c'est le centre
de houston c'est la grande base des
astronautes c'est
trois mille personnes dans une dimanche
bo team ans il ya c'est là où il ya les
piscines l'entraînement où on s'entraîne
pour le toutes les opérations en
scaphandre avant que la nasa accorde sa
confiance à thomas pesquet et lui disent
tu es prêt à faire une sortie en
scaphandre il a fait je peux vous dire
il en a fait des plongées dans ce dans
cette piscine à houston oui ça dure
combien de temps des années peut-être la
préparation cette mission non c'est pas
des années mais c'est enfin c'est
vraiment l'entraînement en piscine c'est
les conditions réelles c'est-à-dire
qu'on est il est en apesanteur et la
seule différence c'est que il est freiné
un petit peu par l'eau c'est pas comme
dans le vide spatial mais il ya là des
orientations il ya plus de hauts et de
bas il est voilà le fait d'être en
plongée dans et il a dû dérouler un faux
panneaux solaires d'un bolide rouge mais
il apprend il apprend à se servir de la
visseuse qu'on a vu tout à l'heure qu'il
avait en main il apprend les procédures
pour se déplacer le long de maquettes de
la station donc avec les les parties on
a vu les prises qui sont faites pour
s'accrocher les il a appris à utiliser
ces lignes de vie et jamais en toujours
gardé une accrocher la station tout ça
c'est les gestes presque une routine qui
l'a prise à houston on retourne dans
l'espace du coup avec ces images en
direct mais il y en a on a un fond de
crépuscule donc on a encore sur le fond
de terre qui est encore un peu vite le
lien très intime et donc là c'est
shenkin brocchi prix qui fait derniers
préparatifs sur ces panneaux solaires
qui sont enroulés donc c'est des gros
cylindre gros cylindre qui ont été
reportés d'un station par une fusée de
spe 6 une capsule dragon et je peux dire
des panneaux ils sont vraiment gros il
tenait à peine dans la largeur de la
fusée donc c'était c'est quelque chose
et une charge importante
et d'ailleurs ils étaient envoyés en
même temps que les astronautes non c'est
l'émission c'est pareil ses missions
cargo donc c'est assez une capsule qui
ressemble d'ailleurs à la capsule dans
laquelle thomas pasquet partie un espace
c'est juste que elle n'en porte que du
coût du matériel
elle emporte donc du matériel à changer
ou à remplacer sous la station et à
chaque fois on emporte aussi de
l'oxygène de l'eau et
et du carburant parce qu'il faut
maintenir la station à poste il faut de
manière régulière
vergne a provisionné il faut il faut
fait actionner les moteurs de la station
pour la faire remonter éviter qu'elle
redescende trouve idiot la terre dans la
caméra de casques 20 donc c'est la
caméra de casques de thomas pesquet on a
perdu là on a donc shenkin bros à gauche
et thomas pesquet à droite thomas
pasquet on reconnaît il a les bandes
rouges autour des cuisses elles sont
elles sont sombres noir mais c'est comme
ça qu'on reconnaît qu'il a le scaphandre
c'est lui qui est sorti le premier de la
station ils sentaient du sas
donc c'est je pense que silhouette très
fier de sa tombe à pic puisque l'os dans
ses deux premières sorties il était
sorti avec avec le même avec le même
look avec chic ymbro mais chaîne qui
brouillent l'avait déjà fait des sorties
en scaphandre lui à partir de la navette
spatiale ont je crois que c'était en
2008 donc il était déjà un vétéran 2 on
voyait tout à l'heure sur le comment
talonnade sur le panneau de la nasa ont
ils disent c'est space rock c'est
l'homme qui marche dans le temps
l'espace et donc c'était un il avait
déjà sur nous non aux familles les space
bondi de sceller spéciaux que celles et
ceux qui ont fait des sorties en
scaphandre c'est vraiment une partie à
part des astros des astronautes tous les
astronautes n'ont pas fait des parcs des
sorties en scaphandre thomas pesquet il
fait partie de ce club assez restreint
et c'est vraiment à la fois une chance
pour lui est un honneur et une pression
supplémentaire parce que c'est c'est
difficile c'est dangereux il en
scaphandre c'est des missions qui sont
cruciales parce que c'est l'entretien la
station c'est en 2007 c'était remplacer
les batteries pour changer des systèmes
qui était vieillissant là c'est rajouter
de nouveaux panneaux solaires pour
donner une garantie de vie plus longue à
la station donc c'est l'émission qui
sont qui sont critiques donc quand la
nasa choisi un astronaute européen et
comme comme thomas pesquet pour faire
ces actions là il un scaphandre nasa il
est il est commandé à houston il est il
est comme un instrument de la nasa dont
pourront dire qu'ils ont mis en lui une
confiance énorme et j'essaie de voir là
si c'est lui qu'on voit à l'image du
grand chose on va pas pouvoir continuer
ce live est encore très très longtemps
mais vous pourrez suivre la suite sur la
chaîne youtube de l'anah
un qui nous qui nous fournit ces images
on va regarder encore une dernière fois
un petit peu ce qui se passe en direct
pour pour voir si on arrive à décrypter
quoi que ce soit alors là on voit donc
le bras le bras robotique donc c'est la
grue de la station on voit thomas
pesquet ça y est installée au bout on le
voit à droite la tête en bas on voit son
scaphandre qui brille le casque dans son
scaphandre qui brille un petit peu on
voit les bandes rouges sur ses cuisses
que son gros sac dans le dos avec
l'oxygène et l'énergie attaques non il
ya aussi son petit jet pack est fixé à
sa wii est donc là il va pouvoir venir
saisir les les panneaux solaires et les
mettra poste donc on n'est pas loin de
la phase vraiment je pense qu'il va être
un peu assez spécial dans cette sortie
on voyait aussi tout à l'heure à la fois
les panneaux solaires et les radiateurs
vu qu'ils n'ont pas la même couleur
caméra de casques 22 je crois que c'est
shane kim gros on voit le 22 en
incrustation en bas à droite c'est comme
ça qui est ça comme ça que le houston
peut savoir qui kiffent il me croirez
film quoi on à sa ligne de vie l'a
accroché à une poignée nous devions
rappel c'est le sait ce qu'ils voient s
qui raccroche la sono l'astronaute en
permanence à la station il en a deux et
il ya eu nos permanences qui de
t'accrocher comme en escalade et je vois
pas bien ce qu'il en train de faire chez
nous qui mord donc les îles et sur la
palette il est il est autour de la
palette qui supportent qui tient les
panneaux solaires qui vont être changés
il a donc il a dû davis et les dernières
bien des écrous qui retenaient les
panneaux solaires alors à cette palette
et alors là les problèmes de liaison
convoi avec cette caméra c'est c'est
pousser cet étonnant puisque de ce
direct non mais il ya des cadets
pas de problème de surchauffe le relais
il ya le relais entre laquelle le casque
est là et la ss la station donc là il ya
quelques mètres donc c'est assez facile
après il faut que l'information elle
passe par des satellites de relais de la
nasa
des satellites qui sont décédés les
communications et donc qu'ils sont
disposés autour de la terre et qui sont
pas forcément dans la meilleure position
pour avoir le signal de l'est de la
station
donc il ya des moments où la
transmission est un petit peu moins
bonne mais c'est passager l'aller
l'image est redevenu excellente donc ça
peut être la lisons casque casque
station qui pas moins bonnes parce qu'il
est derrière un obstacle je ne sais pas
à fond vous donc là c'est shane kim
brossé l'américain on voit la tête en
bas pour lui ça veut rien dire parce
qu'il ya pas de hauts et de bas il n'y a
pas le problème du champ qui monte à la
tête et les pattes non il n'ya pas deux
fois l'hymne du tout il a il nous conte
voici une dizaine de ces lignes de vie
qui pend vers le bas il est en train de
de dévisser je pense les dernières
fixation qui raccroche le les panneaux
solaires donc les panneaux solaires sont
les grands grands cylindres des grands
tubes
asseyez on voit on voit le cash a été
enlevé on voit là un peu je voulais
passer un peu doré un peu marre on a à
droite là c'est vraiment la partie du
panneau solaire qui va être exposé au
soleil
donc il y avait un cash blanc qui était
devant qui a été enlevé donc la partie
de ce moment là il faut faire il faut
faire vraiment attention n'a pas percuté
cette partie là qui est fragile et qui
est celle qui va se dérouler pour donner
aux panneaux solaires sa forme finale
je pense que dans les procédures chinkin
bros et thomas pesquet vont rester bien
à gauche en évitant de se mettre du côté
fragile aliagas qui nous pose une
question dans le tchat sur notre page
youtube qui nous demandent combien de
temps dure l'opération donc si vous nous
rejoignez effectivement cette opération
de remplacement fasse pas vraiment
remplacement mais d'équipement de la
station spatiale internationale en
nouveaux panneaux solaires va prendre
six heures et demie et on est à presque
la moitié de la mission fait oui ce fait
deux heures car de faire un coup et donc
on n'est pas loin de la moitié et j'ai
l'impression que tout se déroule comme
comme prévu il n'y a pas eu il n'y a pas
eu de souci apparent les deux
astronautes se connaissent bien ils
avaient thomas pesquet schenk est mort
en 2017 comme s'ils avaient fait leur
sortie ensemble ils avaient eu mais
presque
je sais plus presque une heure et demie
d'avancé sur le planning c'est rare de
finir avant ça c'était vraiment un des
critères qui montrait que qu'ils avaient
été très bons tous les deux et c'est mon
avis et voilà c'est aussi une des
raisons pour laquelle thomas pasquet
choisi de nouveau cette fois ci pour
cette fois ci pour faire cette tâche si
importante avec en plus le miroir sur
son scaphandre il est sorti le premier
du sas donc il n'est plus le petit
rookie le petit débutant qui frenchy
débutant il et il est vraiment
expérimenté il fait son job et la nasa
lui fait confiance donc c'est vraiment
une belle réussite est on est on est
fier de lui
si vous nous rejoignez c'est bientôt la
fin de ce direct nous étions en direct
depuis maintenant une heure quarante
noms 1h10 pardon pour suivre cette
troisième sortie de l'astronaute
français thomas pesquet dans l'espace
pour une mission de deux fixations de
panneaux solaires donc nous en sommes
quasiment à la moitié on va dire de
cette mission qui doit durer six heures
trente ans tout en ce moment les images
qui nous parviennent en direct depuis
l'iss s sont dans la phase de nuit comme
on dit donc on ne voit pas grand chose
on va pas pouvoir poursuivre plus
longtemps en tout cas vous avez été très
nombreux à nous suivre cette mission va
se poursuivre bien sûr sur la chaîne
youtube de la nasa qui est la source
officielle de toutes les images qu'on
vous a montré en direct pendant ce live
merci beaucoup à cyril van lerberghe qui
a été notre expert qui a commenté toutes
ces images avec nous en direct qui a
répondu à toutes vos questions et elles
étaient nombreuses
tiens à vous remercier pour votre
participation dans le chatt merci à noël
michael à madame sharp est à laâyoune
alice gaspé à qui d'autre a posé
beaucoup de questions à saugnac amis qui
nous suit depuis le début merci merci
d'avoir été avec nous et qui nous a
quittés il ya quelques instants nous
souhaitant une bonne fin d'aprèm est un
très bon travail à thomas et qui
souligne
et qui applaudit son courage voilà on va
vous quitter sur les images en direct de
la nasa
elles sont de lui mais elles sont quand
même très joli à bientôt sur figaro live